This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. One of the first television crime dramas in the United States debuted in 1958. The same guys wearing rubber Halloween masks, one of them with a sword or shotgun. They've knocked off 16 pawn shops liquor stores. Naked City told stories of detectives in New York's 65th precinct. Each episode was a new case. I'm not saying the money he drifted off with is yours, but it's somebody and it's good
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。美国最早的电视犯罪剧之一于1958年首播。同样是那些戴着橡胶万圣节面具的人，其中一个拿着剑或猎枪。他们抢劫了16家当铺和酒类商店。《裸城》讲述了纽约第65分局侦探的故事。每一集都是一个新的案件。我不是说他卷走的钱是你的，但那是别人的，而且是实打实的
hard cash. The premise of the show? There are good guys and there are bad guys. Let me tell you something, Mr. We've got you nailed pretty good. At the end of every episode, the narrator declared, There are 8 million stories in the naked city. This has been one of them. The
硬现金。节目的前提是什么？有好人，也有坏人。我告诉你一件事，先生。我们已经把你抓个正着了。在每一集的结尾，旁白都会宣布：“裸城有8百万个故事。这只是其中之一。”
60 Years Later, Crime dramas haven't changed much. There are still good guys and bad guys, but the bad guys are now savage, remorseless, beyond redemption. So it's their throat so they can't scrape. What the hell's wrong with this guy? I think he's jacked a river. The way we think about crime dramas
60年后，犯罪剧并没有太大的改变。仍然有好人和坏人，但现在的坏人变得残忍、毫无悔意、无可救药。所以是割断他们的喉咙，让他们无法发出声音。这家伙到底怎么了？我想他抢劫了一条河流。我们对犯罪剧的看法
is very similar to the way we think about crime dramas is very similar to the way we think about crime. Homicide, robberies and other kinds of violent crime have been spiking in many big cities in the United States in recent years. Coming after a long period of declining crime rates, this has caused people in many areas to demand solutions, to demand that the good guys catch the bad guys. But it turns out there are some profound mistakes we are making in thinking about crime, both in police traumas and in actual policing. Why are people in this situation, why are they making these choices?
与我们对犯罪的看法非常相似，这与我们对犯罪的看法非常相似。近年来，谋杀、抢劫和其他类型的暴力犯罪在美国许多大城市激增。在经历了长期的犯罪率下降之后，这导致许多地区的民众要求解决问题，要求好人抓坏人。但事实证明，我们在思考犯罪时犯了一些严重的错误，无论是在警察创伤还是在实际警务中。为什么人们会处于这种境地，为什么他们会做出这些选择？
And importantly, what can we do as a society to make things better? This week on Hidden Brain, a subtle insight that could radically transform our approach to crime. In 2016, Sarah Heller began teaching a class on criminology. She was looking for a way to teach her students about the economics of crime. She turned to a respected source. It was the boy's dream. The angel of such a man. It was the hit HBO series The Wire. The wire is the story of Baltimore Street crime and the drug gangs were working there and the police were trying to stop them and
更重要的是，作为一个社会，我们能做些什么来让事情变得更好？本周的“隐藏大脑”将探讨一个微妙的见解，它可能从根本上改变我们对待犯罪的方法。2016年，莎拉·海勒开始教授一门犯罪学课程。她一直在寻找一种方法，向学生们教授犯罪经济学。她转向了一个受人尊敬的来源。那是男孩的梦想。这种人的天使。那是HBO的热门剧集《火线》。《火线》讲述了巴尔的摩街头犯罪以及在那里运作的贩毒帮派的故事，警察试图阻止他们，
the way that it affects the citizenry of Baltimore. If you haven't seen the show, we are going to have spoilers. Season three of the wire features growing tensions between two leaders of a drug gang. One wants to run the business, like a business. The other says, you don't get it. You're not a businessman. You're a criminal. Embrace it. Yeah, so the whole season, or for even three seasons, you've gotten to know Stranger Bell,
以及它如何影响巴尔的摩的市民。如果你没看过这部剧，我们要剧透了。《火线》第三季讲述了贩毒集团两个头目之间日益紧张的关系。一个人想把生意当作生意来经营。另一个人说，你不明白。你不是一个商人。你是个罪犯。接受它吧。是的，所以整整季，甚至整整三季，你都开始了解斯特林格·贝尔，
who's one of the heads of the gang. He's also sort of interested in trying to have some legal businesses and trying to develop a real estate career and balancing those two things. There's been sort of growing and growing disagreement between him and the other person who leads the gang with him, Avaan Barksdale. You know what, I look at you these days, you know what I see? I see a man without a country. Avaan wants to think about gangs and territory and building up as a gang leader and he disagrees with stringers desire to be more of a legal player and to minimize the violence.
他是帮派头目之一。他也对尝试经营合法生意、发展房地产事业以及平衡这两件事感兴趣。他和与他一起领导帮派的另一个人阿凡·巴克斯代尔之间，分歧越来越大。你知道吗，我这些天看着你，你知道我看到了什么吗？我看到了一个没有国家的男人。阿凡想考虑帮派、地盘以及作为帮派头目的建设，他不同意斯特林格想要成为更多合法玩家并尽量减少暴力的愿望。
Well, because I don't shoot up a block in this criminal, I ain't hard enough. In a climactic scene, Ava and Barxtail betrays his friend and partner. Stringer Bell finds himself in a building unarmed and alone with an exceptionally violent criminal who holds a grudge against him. Stringer tries to reason his way out of the trap,
嗯，因为我没有在一个街区里开枪打死一个罪犯，我不够强硬。在一个高潮迭起的场景中，阿凡·巴克斯代尔背叛了他的朋友和伙伴。斯特林格·贝尔发现自己在一个建筑物里，手无寸铁，孤身一人，面对一个对他怀恨在心的极其暴力的罪犯。斯特林格试图用理智摆脱这个陷阱，
but it doesn't work. It seems like I can't say nothing to change your minds. We'll get on with it. What was your student's reactions when you showed them this season? It must have been an engaging way to start a class that looked at the economics of crime and drug markets. So I think in some respects it blows their mind partly because it was the 90s and they don't know what the 90s looked like. So that's a learning experience too.
但没用。看来我说什么也改变不了你们的主意了。那就继续吧。当你向学生展示这一季时，他们的反应是什么？这一定是一个引人入胜的方式来开始一门审视犯罪经济学和毒品市场的课程。所以我认为在某些方面这让他们大开眼界，部分原因是那是90年代，他们不知道90年代是什么样子的。所以这也是一种学习经历。
But I think they learn to think about things not through the lens of politics or their prior beliefs about what they think crime is like or what they think policing is like. But they learn to think about why are people in this situation, why are they making these choices, and how can we shape policy to improve this situation? Part of its use is that it helps students become social scientists and think about, why do things work the way that they do,
但我认为他们学会了不是通过政治的镜头，或者他们对犯罪是什么样子的先前信念，或者他们对警务是什么样子的先前信念来思考事情。但他们学会了思考为什么人们会处于这种境地，为什么他们会做出这些选择，以及我们如何塑造政策来改善这种局面？它的部分用途在于它帮助学生成为社会科学家并思考，为什么事情会按照它们的方式运作，
and importantly, why do people participate in crime? Why are they willing to put themselves at sometimes moral risk for this kind of lifestyle? And how does policing work? And what are police trying to do? And how well do they do it? And what's effective? And what's not effective?
更重要的是，为什么人们会参与犯罪？为什么他们愿意为了这种生活方式而承担有时是道德上的风险？警务是如何运作的？警察在试图做什么？他们做得怎么样？什么有效？什么无效？
And importantly, what can we do as a society to make things better? I want to go back a second to that scene at the end of season three of the wire, because of course there's a second subtext that runs through that scene that is again I think implicit in our understanding of how crime operates and what the police do, which is that you have something happen, someone gets shot, stringerbells lying dead on the ground, and then the police do, which is that you have something happen, someone gets shot, stringer bells lying dead on the ground, and then the police come in, basically try and figure out what happened and try and solve the crime.
更重要的是，作为一个社会，我们能做些什么来让事情变得更好？我想回到《火线》第三季结尾的那个场景，因为那个场景中当然还有第二个潜台词，我认为这再次隐含在我们对犯罪运作方式和警察职责的理解中，也就是会发生一些事情，有人被枪击，斯特林格·贝尔倒在地上死去，然后警察做的事情是，会发生一些事情，有人被枪击，斯特林格·贝尔倒在地上死去，然后警察进来，基本上试图弄清楚发生了什么并试图破案。
And of course, that's the model that we have is that the only way in which we can intervene is once we know when something is wrong. And we have to investigate what happened and try and find the people who did the bad thing and bring them to justice. Can you just talk about that idea that in some ways we have a fundamental model of how crime is supposed to operate that almost begins at the point that the trigger is pulled. I think that's right. And I think part of the reason we might have that model in our head is because we are thinking about solving crimes. We want to wait to the point where something has gone wrong, to then think about who did it,
当然，这就是我们的模式，即我们能够干预的唯一方式是一旦我们知道出了什么问题。我们必须调查发生了什么，并试图找到做了坏事的人并将他们绳之以法。你能谈谈这种想法吗？在某种程度上，我们有一个关于犯罪应该如何运作的基本模式，几乎从扣动扳机的那一刻开始。我认为这是对的。我认为我们脑海中可能有这个模式的部分原因是我们在考虑破案。我们想等到出了问题的那一刻，然后考虑是谁干的，
right, which is sort of necessarily retrospective. Intervening after the trigger is pulled means police are playing catch-up. Increasingly, some police departments, with the help of social scientists, have tried to be more proactive. They found that if you collect large amounts of police data and crunch it algorithmically, you can start to predict future criminal activity. In a previous episode, we explored how gun violence spreads through networks of people like an infectious disease. It's a very specific kind of infection. Here's how sociologist Andrew Papacristos described it to me.
对吧，这在某种程度上必然是回顾性的。在扣动扳机后进行干预意味着警察在赶进度。越来越来多的警察部门在社会科学家的帮助下，试图采取更加积极主动的态度。他们发现，如果你收集大量的警察数据并用算法进行处理，你就可以开始预测未来的犯罪活动。在上一集里，我们探讨了枪支暴力如何在人群网络中像传染病一样蔓延。这是一种非常特殊的感染。社会学家安德鲁·帕帕克里斯托斯是这样向我描述的。
It tends to be very specific behaviors, risky behaviors, that put you in these networks. And in some ways it becomes much more like the spread of diseases through needle sharing or unprotected sex, rather than catching a bullet from somebody sneezing. There's lots of evidence that violence is very concentrated, both among people and among geography. And so, you know, there's sort of a bunch of analytic work trying to figure out which blocks of which neighborhoods are likely to have the most gun violence. And there, it's a little bit easier to think about how do we put police resources where the most crime is happening. There's lots of evidence that that is successful and especially with violent crime, it does respond to increased policing.
它往往是非常具体的行为，即那些把你置于这些网络中的危险行为。在某些情况下，它变得更像是通过共用针头或无保护性行为传播疾病，而不是接住某人打喷嚏时的子弹。有大量证据表明，暴力高度集中在人群和地理位置上。所以，你知道，有一堆分析工作试图弄清楚哪些街区的枪击暴力可能最多。在那里，考虑如何将警察资源投入到犯罪发生最多的地方会稍微容易一些。有大量证据表明这是成功的，尤其是对于暴力犯罪，它确实会对增加的警力做出反应。
But relying on police data to build a model of future criminal activity has two big problems. First, if you care about civil liberties, it could make you uneasy. If I think you are likely to commit a crime in the future, I might be tempted to monitor where you go and what you do, even though you haven't done anything wrong. There's a second big problem with building predictive algorithms from police data. There's a lot of evidence that police data are not a perfect measure of underlying behavior, right? They're a combination of individuals' behavior and police decision-making, right? Who they decide to stop, who they decide to arrest if you're using arrest records.
但是依赖警察数据来建立未来犯罪活动的模型有两个大问题。首先，如果你关心公民自由，这可能会让你感到不安。如果我认为你将来可能会犯罪，我可能会忍不住监视你去哪里、做什么，尽管你没有做错任何事。利用警察数据建立预测算法还有第二个大问题。有大量证据表明，警察数据并不是对潜在行为的完美衡量，对吧？它们是个人行为和警察决策的结合，对吧？他们决定拦下谁，如果你使用逮捕记录的话，他们决定逮捕谁。
And I think what the evidence suggests is that a combination of police officers implicit bias and sometimes outright racism, generates a set of arrests that don't mean the same thing for the same people, right? That they might be potentially if police are more likely to arrest young black men, then it's gonna look like young black men are risky or just because of police decision-making
我认为证据表明，警察的隐性种族偏见和有时赤裸裸的种族主义的结合，产生了一组逮捕记录，对不同的人并不意味着相同的事情，对吧？如果警察更有可能逮捕年轻黑人男性，那么这可能会显示年轻黑人男性具有风险，但这仅仅是因为警察的决策，
and not because of actual risk level. And is these kinds of biases and algorithms that I think have become a really important central part of the conversation about how we should be using prediction methods? Many critics have said police data might be very good at predicting future police behavior. Prior arrests the police make are a strong predictor of future arrests.
而不是因为实际的风险水平。我认为正是这种偏见和算法，成为了关于我们应该如何使用预测方法的话语中一个非常重要且核心的部分。许多批评人士表示，警察数据可能非常擅长预测未来的警察行为。警察先前的逮捕记录是未来逮捕的强烈预测指标。
But does this data really paint an accurate picture of offenders? The people actually committing crimes. Sarah, who now teaches at the University of Michigan, said police data cannot be simply taken to be an unbiased account of criminal behavior. Rather, it's an account of criminal behavior as observed by and reported to the police. But then you have to stop and look at that and think, how do I know if this is a good prediction? And you might be very good at predicting police behavior,
但这些数据真的能准确描绘罪犯的画像吗？真正犯罪的人。现在在密歇根大学任教的莎拉说，不能简单地将警察数据视为对犯罪行为的不偏不倚的描述。相反，它是对警察观察到并向警察报告的犯罪行为的描述。但随后你必须停下来看看这一点，并思考，我怎么知道这是一个好的预测？你可能非常擅长预测警察行为，
but in fact, you have no idea whether you're actually predicting actual offending behavior. And there's just no solution to that because we don't have other good measures of who's actually pulling the trigger. So we have a lot of data from police arrest records and other police information. But as you say, when two people call the police to investigate different incidents, even if the incidents are more or less identical, the police response to those incidents might not be identical.
但事实上，你根本不知道你是否真的在预测实际的犯罪行为。而且对此毫无解决办法，因为我们没有其他好的方法来衡量到底是谁在扣动扳机。所以我们有来自警察逮捕记录和其他警察信息的大量数据。但正如你所说，当两个人报警调查不同的事件时，即使这些事件或多或少是相同的，警察对这些事件的反应也可能不尽相同。
And if they're not identical, then the data that goes into the police system is going to be biased, not by the difference between the underlying incidents, but the difference in the police response to those incidents. I want you to talk a moment here about the insight that you had, which is that if we stipulate that predicting future crimes is difficult because of these biases that are implicit in the police records. What is the solution to that? Because of course, we are reliant on police data in terms of figuring out what happens. They're the people who we call when something happens, when there's a crime that takes
如果它们不尽相同，那么进入警察系统的就会是带偏见的数据，这种偏见不是由潜在事件之间的差异造成的，而是由警察对这些事件反应的差异造成的。我想请你谈谈你当时的那个见解，即如果我们假设由于警察记录中隐含的这些偏见，预测未来的犯罪很困难，那么解决方案是什么？因为当然，在弄清楚发生了什么方面，我们依赖于警察数据。当发生事情、发生犯罪时，我们叫的人就是他们。
place. So if you have this flawed data, how do you make more sense of it for it to become more useful? So the realization that we had is that arrests for shooting at homicide are not our only measure of gun violence in the police data. We can also measure victimization. Victimization. Go back to that scene at the end of season three of the wire. Once the police find someone has been killed, they start to investigate. They carry out forensic tests, they conduct interviews, they make arrests.
所以如果你有这些有缺陷的数据，你如何更好地理解它，使其变得更有用？所以我们意识到的事情是，枪击和谋杀的逮捕并不是我们在警察数据中衡量枪支暴力的唯一标准。我们还可以衡量受害情况。受害情况。回到《火线》第三季结尾的那个场景。一旦警察发现有人被杀，他们就开始调查。他们进行法医测试，进行面谈，实施逮捕。
All of this information goes into the police database. If you are worried about police impartiality, you might worry about the integrity of this data. But there is one aspect of the data that is virtually certain to be uncontaminated by bias. It's the fact that stringer bell is lying on the ground, dead. What we have is a measure of whether someone is shot.
所有这些信息都进入了警察数据库。如果你担心警察的公正性，你可能会担心这些数据的完整性。但数据中有一个方面几乎可以肯定是未受偏见污染的。那就是斯特林格·贝尔倒在地上死去了。我们掌握的是衡量某人是否被中枪的标准。
And so almost all cases where someone is shot end up in police records because people seek medical treatment and the medical staff are required to tell the police. So in other words, let's say there's someone who gets shot on a street corner. It's possible that police have some leads on a suspect. It's possible that they find a suspect. It's possible they found the right suspect, it's also possible police bias is involved in identifying the suspect or tracking down
因此，几乎所有有人中枪的案件都会进入警察记录，因为人们会寻求医疗救助，而医务人员被要求告知警察。换句话说，假设有人在街角中枪。警察有可能掌握了一些嫌疑人的线索，有可能找到了嫌疑人，也有可能找到了正确的嫌疑人，警察在确认嫌疑人或追踪嫌疑人时也可能涉及偏见，
the person, but the one thing we absolutely know for sure is we know the person lying on the street in a pool of blood, we know who that person is and we know that that's happened. That's right and I think you know people might worry that in some cases if you're shot you would be afraid to go to the police. You might not want to report it to the police. But even if the police aren't there, even if you're not shot so badly that you're lying on the sidewalk, but you can walk away, you are very likely to go to the hospital to get medical treatment. Almost everybody seeks medical treatment, even if they're not willing to call the police. And once they do that, you still show up in the police data.
但有一件事我们绝对可以确定，那就是我们知道那个躺在街头血泊中的人是谁，我们也知道这件事发生了。没错，我认为人们可能会担心，在某些情况下，如果你中枪了，你可能会害怕去找警察。你可能不想向警察报案。但即使警察不在场，即使你中枪没有严重到躺在人行道上，但你还能走开，你极有可能会去医院接受医疗治疗。几乎每个人都会寻求医疗治疗，即使他们不愿意报警。一旦他们这样做了，你依然会出现在警察数据中。
Sarah and her colleagues asked themselves a question. Police data about previous arrests were being used to identify people at high risk or future arrest. Could the same data identify people at high risk of becoming future victims? They got access to data from the Chicago Police Department over a 20-year period.
莎拉和她的同事们问了自己一个问题。关于先前逮捕的警察数据被用来识别面临未来逮捕高风险的人。同样的数据能否识别出面临未来受害高风险的人？他们获得了芝加哥警察局20年间的数据。
The data included information about police arrests for minor crimes like vandalism, to major crimes like shootings or robbery. Sarah and her colleagues built a machine learning model that crunched the data looking for patterns. It found a match. By looking at prior arrests and other police data, the model pinpointed people at high risk
这些数据包括关于警察对轻微犯罪（如破坏公物）到重大犯罪（如枪击或抢劫）的逮捕信息。莎拉和她的同事建立了一个机器学习模型，通过处理数据来寻找模式。它找到了匹配项。通过查看先前的逮捕记录和其他警察数据，该模型精确定位了高风险人群
of becoming future shooting victims. How accurate was this prediction? Sarah picked out a sample of more than 300,000 people from the police database and tracked them over the next 18 months to see if the prediction was accurate. It did sort of start to linger well, or it did sort of shockingly well, where if you take those 330,000 people,
成为未来枪击受害者。这个预测有多准？莎拉从警察数据库中挑选了30万人的样本，并在接下来的18个月里追踪他们，以查看预测是否准确。它开始表现得很好，或者说表现得令人震惊地好，如果你把这33万人都算上，
we have some predicted probability that each person is going to get shot in the next 18 months. Line them up in order of risk level and look just at the 500 people with the highest predicted risk. So the very smallest group with a very highest risk, and it turns out that of those 500 people with the highest predicted risk, 13% of them are shot in the next 18 months. And that's just a shocking risk of something as serious as a shooting victimization, right? So think about being in a crowded movie theater, about 500 people, and I tell you 13% of that
我们对每个人在接下来的18个月内被枪击的概率有某种预测。按风险水平将他们排成一行，仅看预测风险最高的前500人。也就是风险最高的那个极小群体，结果发现，在这500名预测风险最高的人中，有13%的人在接下来的18个月内中枪了。这对于枪击受害这样严重的事情来说，是一个令人震惊的风险，对吧？所以想想在一个拥挤的电影院里，大约有500人，我告诉你这个群体中将有13%的人在未来一年半内被枪击。这是一种潜在致命暴力的非凡风险。这个比率是芝加哥人平均水平的130倍。因此，我们可以找到一小群面临极端高枪击风险的人。我的意思是，能够做到这一点几乎显得有些诡异，能够说，我能告诉你，在一个300万人口的城市里，接下来的18个月里谁会被枪击。我的意思是，这几乎令人感到可怕的诡异。
group is going to be shot in the next year and a half. That's an extraordinary risk of potentially lethal violence. It's a rate that's 130 times higher than the average Chicago in. So we can find a relatively small group of people that are just at an extraordinarily high risk of being shot. I mean, it almost seems spooky to be able to do that, to be able to say, I can tell you in the next 18 months who's going to get shot in a city of 3 million people. I mean, that's almost scary spooky.
这确实有点令人不安。我的意思是，想象一下有人来对你说，你在接下来的18个月里中枪的几率超过十分之一。这实际上可能会激励你参与芝加哥现在试图提供的一些项目。这当然不是完美的预测，对吧？13%的比率意味着这个群体中还有87%的人没有中枪。
It is a little bit disturbing. I mean, imagine someone coming to you and saying, you have more than a one-in-10 chance of being shot in the next 18 months. It might, in fact, motivate you to participate in some of these programs that Chicago is now trying to offer. And it's certainly not perfect prediction, right? A 13% rate means there's also 87% of the people who are in that group who are not shot.
这不是完美的预测。但我们能够以如此高的风险找到这么小的一个群体，这一事实确实凸显了我认为我们应该做更多事情来帮助他们，对吧？我们知道他们是谁。我们不知道每个人是谁，但我们知道一小群面临如此高风险的人，我们真的应该花更多钱来努力确保他们的安全。在这样做时有一个巨大的障碍。我稍后会详细解释。但我想停下来强调一下莎拉的微妙见解。
It's not a perfect prediction. But the fact that we can find such a small group at such an extraordinarily high risk really sort of highlights, I think, the fact that we should be doing more to help them, right? We know who they are. We don't know who everybody is, but we know a small set of people at such high risk that we really should be spending more to try to help keep them safe. There is a huge obstacle in doing that. I'll explain more in a moment. But I want to stop and underscore Sarah's subtle insight.
利用警察记录来预测谁将在未来卷入犯罪，冒着像电影《少数派报告》中那种反乌托邦反应的风险，即警察在罪犯犯罪之前就去追捕他们。这引发了关于公民自由、偏见和监控的令人不安的问题。但使用警察数据不再是为了描绘潜在枪手的画像，而是描绘潜在枪击受害者的画像，这样问题就变得没那么棘手了。如果我告诉你你面临在未来做坏事的风险，你可能会气恼。
Using police records to predict who is going to be involved in crime in the future, runs the risk of the dystopian response you see in movies like Minority Report, where police go after criminals before they have committed crimes. It raises troubling questions about civil liberties, bias, and surveillance. But it becomes much less problematic to use the police data, not to paint a picture of would-be shooters, but a picture of would be shooting victims. If I told you that you were at risk of doing something bad in the future, you might bristle.
但如果我告诉你，你面临未来遭遇不幸的风险，你可能会听进去。这就是医生每天为病人做的事情。为什么将莎拉的见解应用於保护枪击受害者会很难呢？为此，你必须问自己一个问题。为什么过去逮捕的警察数据在预测哪些人会在接下来的18个月内中枪方面如此有效？在犯罪学中，有大量证据表明受害者和罪犯往往是同一个人。
But if I told you that you were at risk of something bad happening to you in the future, you might listen. It's what doctors do for patients every day. Why would it be hard to apply Sarah's insight to protect shooting victims? For that, you have to ask yourself a question. Why would police data on past arrests be so effective at predicting which people would get shot in the next 18 months? In criminology, there's lots of evidence that victims and offenders tend to be the same
这当然并非总是如此。你可以想到很多不成立的例子，比如家庭暴力受害者或旁观者。但事实是，导致你面临中枪风险的那些危险行为，也可能是让你成为罪犯或卷入其他犯罪的同类危险行为。因此，用莎拉的见解做任何有用事情的巨大障碍是我们自己。
people. This is certainly not always true. You can think of a lot of examples where it's not true, domestic violence, victims, for instance, or bystanders. But it is the case that the kinds of risky behaviors that lead you to be at risk of being shot may also be the same kinds of risky behaviors that make you likely to be an offender or be involved in other crime. So the big obstacle to doing anything useful with Sarah's insight is us.
当我们看到斯特林格·贝尔倒在地上时，我们大多数人不会说，真是个悲剧。我们会说，他期望什么？如果你经营一个帮派或者打过其他人，就会有人把你当作目标。莎拉说，犯罪的纯粹代价和预防它的好处要求我们彻底反思。所以我认为政策制定者有一种本能的理解，即预防可能比事后补救更好，对吧？如果你能阻止某件社会代价很高的事情
When we see Stringer Bell lying on the ground, most of us don't say, what a tragedy. We say, what did he expect? If you run a gang or a hit some other people, someone is going to have you in their crosshairs. Sarah says the sheer cost of crime and the benefits of preventing it call for an overhaul in our thinking. So I think policymakers have an innate understanding that prevention might be better than remediation, right? That if you can keep something that's very socially costly
发生，我们就应该努力去做。所以这不一定是那种你只是等到事情发生然后惩罚它，然后希望这能改变未来行为的模式。如果你想做的是预防犯罪，那么你就会想要考虑所有可以预防它的方式。因此，这不仅是阻止某人
from happening, we should try to do that. And so that's not necessarily the model where you just wait till something happens and punish it, and then hope that sort of changes future behavior. If what you're trying to do is prevent crime, then you wanna think about all of the ways in which you can prevent it. And so that's not just stopping someone
扣动扳机。这也可能是阻止某人陷入可能面临中枪风险的境地。我想知道这项工作的一个重要见解是否是，莎拉，首先且最重要的是从他们遭受受害风险的角度来思考人，而不是首先且最重要的是从他们成为肇事者的风险的角度来思考他们。正如我们所讨论的，这两个世界之间存在重叠。
from pulling a trigger. It might also be stopping someone from being in a position where they would be at risk of being shot. I'm wondering if one of the important insights from this work, Sarah, is the importance of thinking about people in some ways first and foremost in terms of their risk of victimization instead of thinking about them first and foremost in terms of their risk for becoming perpetrators. There is an overlap between those two worlds as we discussed.
但如果我们把你当作潜在的受害者来思考，我认为这改变了人们接近如何看待你的立场。传统模式确实是我们认为某人是个威胁。我们如何在他周围筑起栅栏以防止他伤害其他人？我听到你建议的模式是我们担心某人会成为受害者。我们如何在他身下铺一张安全网以防止他坠落？我想我们可能应该让你从今以后帮我们写论文，因为我认为这是一个非常雄辩的表达方式，对吧？
But if we think about you as a potential victim in some way, I think it changes the orientation with which people approach how they can think of you. The conventional model really is we think that someone's a threat. How do we put a fence around them to keep them from harming other people? And the model that I hear you suggesting is we fear that someone's going to become a victim. How do we put a safety net under them to keep them from falling? I think probably we should just have you write our papers from now on because I think that's a very eloquent way to put it, right?
如果你认为谁面临成为受害者的风险，它就会使人变得人性化。我们想要制止各种形式的受害，对吧？这在我们分配医疗保健的方式上也是如此，对吧？我们试图防止心脏病发作、抑郁症和自杀带来的伤害，我们也试图防止凶杀案带来的伤害。因此，我认为从这个角度出发，我希望这将激励人们更认真地对待预防，
That if you think who's at risk of being a victim, it humanizes people. We want to stop all sorts of victimization, right? And that's true in terms of the way we allocate medical care, right? We try to sort of prevent harm from heart attacks and from depression and suicide, and we try to prevent harm from homicide as well. And so I think coming at it from that perspective, I hope we'll motivate people to take prevention more seriously,
不仅仅是将枪击暴力的问题视为外面有坏人在做坏事，而是思考我们如何才能帮助保护我们社会中最脆弱的一些成员免受伤害。这项工作要求实现一个关键的思维转变。当我们看到斯特林格·贝尔倒在血泊中时，莎拉要求我们的第一反应不是，嗯，他是个罪犯，他罪有应得。相反，她建议我们说，这场死亡，就像任何其他枪击死亡一样，是一个悲剧。
to not just see the problem of gun violence as there are bad people out there doing bad things, but to think about how can we help keep some of the most vulnerable members of our society safe. There is a crucial mind shift that is demanded by this work. When Risi Stringo bell lying in a pool of blood, Sarah asks that our first reaction not be, well, he was a criminal, he had it coming. Instead she is suggesting we say, this death, like any other shooting death, is a tragedy.
我们如何最大限度地减少此类悲剧？她建议，与其提防像斯特林格·贝尔这样的人，不如我们开始照顾他们。现在，这听起来可能有点天真和理想主义。有些人可能会对我们应该竭尽全力挽救以前与暴力犯罪有关的人的生命这一想法感到恼火。但事实证明，如果你开始从罪犯成为
How do we minimize such tragedies? She is suggesting that instead of watching out for people like Stringer Bell, we start to look out for them. Now, this can sound look out for them. Now this can sound naive and idealistic. Some people may bristle at the idea that we should go out of our way to save the lives of people who have been previously linked to violent crime. But it turns out, if you start to think of offenders in terms of their propensity to become
受害者的倾向，而不是他们犯下未来犯罪的倾向来思考他们，你最终会对这两件事情产生深远的影响。这就是我们回归时的情景。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。2004年，克里斯·布拉特曼在内罗毕与刚刚认识的一名男子进行了一次有趣的交谈。我大约30岁。我是一名经济学研究生。我在肯尼亚的内罗毕工作。有一天，我在一家小咖啡馆吃午餐，
victims, instead of their propensity to commit future crimes, you can end up having a profound impact on both those things. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. In 2004, Chris Blatman was having an interesting chat with a man in Nairobi whom he just met. I was about 30 years old. I was an economics graduate student. I was working in Nairobi in Kenya. And one day I was sitting at Verlunch
一个男人和我搭讪，超级健谈，问我在做什么，在研究什么？当我转身面向他而背对背包时，他的同伴抓起背包就走，幸好没拿我的护照。你什么时候发现背包不见了，克里斯？所以，你知道，可能只是在那之后的某个时候，当我起身要离开时，
in a little cafe, and a man strikes me up in conversation, super engaging, what am I doing, what am I working on? And as I'm turned towards him and away from my back back, his pal grabs it and walks off with my laptop, fortunately not with my passport. When did you notice the laptop was gone, Chris? So, you know, probably it was only, sometime afterwards when I got up to leave
纳闷我的背包去哪了，然后我和警察交谈。你知道，那里有个警察，他问：“噢，是不是有人和你搭讪？”我说：“是的。”他说：“对，事情就是这样，孩子。”克里斯转向当地的网吧来完成工作并与同事保持联系。但这些网吧的网速慢得令人痛苦。
and wondered where my backpack was and I spoke to the police. You know, there's a cop there and he was like, oh, did somebody like strike you up in conversation? And I said, yes, and he's like, yeah, that's what happened kid. Chris turned to local internet cafes to do his work and to stay in touch with colleagues. But the internet speed in these cafes was painfully slow.
每加载一条Hotmail邮件大约需要10分钟，所以和旁边的人聊天是习以为常的事，在网吧度过的一两个小时里，你最终会进行很多无聊的闲聊。这就是当时的文化。所以我刻意坐在一个和我年龄相仿的女人旁边，我们最后聊了起来，她是一名心理学家和人道主义工作者，曾在乌干达北部工作过。由被偷的笔记本电脑偶然引发的这次会面证明是很重要的。我们一起写了论文。我们在耶鲁一起找到了第一份工作。我们一起写论文。更重要的是，我们有了两个孩子，现在已经结婚15年了。
It would be about 10 minutes for each hot mail message to load up and so it was customary to talk to the person next to you and just you ended up in a lot of idle chatter over your hour or two on the internet cafe. That was just the culture of the time. And so I purposely sat next to a woman my age and we ended up striking up a conversation and she was a psychologist and humanitarian worker who had been working in northern Uganda. The chance meeting occasioned by the stolen laptop turned out to be important. We wrote our dissertations together. We got our first jobs at Yale together. We wrote papers together. We have had two children together more importantly, and we've now been married for 15 years.
你有没有给偷你笔记本电脑的那个人寄过感谢信？没有，如果我遇到他，我会给他一个感激的拥抱。我会给他一个感激的拥抱。克里斯完成博士学位后，开始在华盛顿特区的一个智库工作。一天，一位同事邀请他出去吃午饭。他想让克里斯见见他在利比里亚合作过的一个人，一个名叫约翰逊·博尔的男子。所以，约翰逊是一个身材魁梧、满脸笑容的壮汉。我对西非人唯一了解的是，
Did you ever send a thank you note to the guy who stole your laptop? No, if I ever meet him, I will give him a grateful hug. I will give him a grateful hug. After Chris finished his PhD, he began working at a think tank in Washington, DC. One day, a colleague asked him out to lunch. He wanted Chris to meet someone he had been working with in Liberia, a man named Johnson Boer. So, Johnson is this sort of big smiling meaty man. And the one thing I knew about West Africans
他可能有一周左右没吃过的一大盘米饭。所以我们去了一家泛亚餐厅。这就是我们结下友谊的方式。他说：“终于有人给我提供我能吃的米饭了，这可以说是通往利比里亚人心的秘诀。”那顿午饭后，克里斯就把约翰逊抛到脑后了，但不久之后，克里斯发现自己身处利比里亚。这个国家正在从内战中恢复。
is that the one thing he probably had not had in a week or so was a huge mountain of rice. And so we went to a Penn Asian restaurant. And that was how we bonded. He was like, finally, someone has offered me the rice that I can eat, which is the secret to a Liberian's heart at turn so. Chris forgot about Johnson after that lunch, but sometime later Chris found himself in Liberia. The country was recovering from civil war.
1989年，一个名叫查尔斯·泰勒的军阀入侵该国并夺取了权力。随之而来的是多年的起义和暴力，直到泰勒最终在2003年被流放至尼日利亚。当我在2008年初抵达时，这个国家正处于和平的第五年。它刚刚举行了一次民主选举，将非洲第一位女总统推上了权力宝座。有15,000名维和部队，所以这是一个充满希望的时刻，但这个地方已经被满目疮痍。当我从机场开车进来时，你会看到到处都是烧毁的建筑物躯壳。国防部是一个黑色的混凝土堆。几乎没有什么公寓楼，我们看到的完全被烧毁了。
In 1989 a warlord named Charles Taylor invaded the country and seized power. What followed was years of uprising and violence until Taylor was finally exiled to Nigeria in 2003. When I arrived in early 2008, the country was in year five of peace. It had just had a democratic election that brought to power Africa's first female president. There were 15,000 peacekeeping troops, so it was a time of hope, but the place was decimated. When I was driving in from the airport, you would see just burned out hulks of buildings everywhere. The Ministry of Defense was a black and concrete pile. With few apartment buildings, there were, we're totally burned out.
没有墙。它只剩下这个混凝土骨架。人们在这些建筑物的不同楼层上搭起了这个12层的防水布城市。你能给我描绘一下利比里亚人民，特别是年轻人的人文发展状况吗？所以这是一个国家，
There were no walls. It was just this concrete skeleton. And people had set up this 12-story tarp city on various floors of these buildings. Can you paint me a picture of what the state of human development among people, especially young people in Liberia? So this was a country that had been decimated of human development among people, especially young people in Liberia.
被14年的政治动荡和战争摧毁了。任何能够逃出去的人都逃出去了。他们去了加纳，去了美国，去了某个地方。任何受过一点教育或有点钱的人都这么做了。留下来的人都从他们的农场、公寓里流离失所，他们失去了拥有的一切。如果你是一个年轻人，没有逃出去，你很有可能会被卷入其中一个
So this was a country that had been decimated by 14 years of political instability in war. Anybody who could get out got out. They went to Ghana, they went to the United States, they went somewhere. And anyone with an ounce of education or money did so. And the people who stayed behind were all displaced from their farm, from their apartment, and they'd lost everything they had. And if you were a young man and you didn't get out, there was a good chance you were pulled into one
武装集团。随着战争结束，许多离开这个国家的人如潮水般涌回。他们开始创业，投资经济，涉足政治。但战争期间被抛在后面的年轻男女在战争结束后依然觉得自己被抛在了后面。他们没有被纳入这股新的发展浪潮中。
armed group or the other. As the war ended, many of the people who had left the country came pouring back in. They were starting businesses, investing in the economy, getting into politics. But the young men and women who were left behind during the war still felt left behind after it was over. They were not included in this new wave of development.
相反，他们发现自己回到了熟悉的生活中。这些人会卖毒品或扒窃。武装抢劫、入室抢劫和持械抢劫越来越多。如果你是总统或联合国维和部队，这些人就是你最关心的人，因为他们将是下一批叛乱者，或者他们可能是邻国内战中的下一批雇佣兵。
Instead, they found themselves returning to the life they knew. These are the guys who would sell drugs or pickpocket. There was a growing amount of armed robbery, home invasions, and muggings. And if you were the president or if you were the UN, peacekeeping force, these guys were your number one concern because these were gonna be the next insurgents or they might be the next mercenaries for the civil war in the country next door.
克里斯开始在一个重返社会中心工作，面临暴力高风险的年轻男女在那里学习耕种。他遇到了他在华盛顿的旧识约翰逊·博尔。约翰逊一直在与受冲突流离失所的人们合作，并在中心提供帮助。一天早晨，克里斯在喊叫声中醒来。他们能听到这种隆隆的撞击声，我们走出我们的小屋，
Chris started working at a reintegration center where young men and women at high risk for violence were learning to farm. He ran into his old DC acquaintance, Johnson Boer. Johnson had been working with people displaced by the conflict and was helping out of the center. One morning, Chris awoke to shouts. They can kind of hear this sort of rumbling and tumble, and we walk from our little hut
走过主建筑，当我们转过拐角时，你知道，噪音越来越大，所有400名前战斗人员都在院子里罢工、大喊、抗议。那天食物没准备好，橡胶靴没有出现。所有这些小怨恨演变成了一场本质上的骚乱，约翰逊就站在他们中间，认为我们已经谈过了，让你们的人回房间去。我们有办法处理这些争端。这不是我们做事的方式。
and pass the main building and as we turn the corner, you know, the noise is getting louder and louder, and all 400 former combatants were striking, yelling, protesting in the yard. The food wasn't ready that day, The rubber boots hadn't shown up. All these little grievances spilled into what essentially became a riot and there was Johnson standing in the middle of them think we have talked about this Get your people back to their rooms. We have ways to deal with these disputes. This is not how we do it.
解决这个问题，因为这会出问题的。他把他们带回了谈判桌，仅仅靠着非凡的意志力，而校园里的其他所有人都逃跑了。所以这个我在华盛顿短暂遇到过的家伙，突然之间有一种神奇的特质，他能够运作和做事，并且有一种魅力、勇敢和这方面的天赋，我只想更多地了解他。克里斯开始在首都蒙罗维亚到处跟随约翰逊。所以，蒙罗维亚是一座建在丛林和沼泽混合地带的城市。就像置身于盛夏的佛罗里达州一样。
Fix this because this is going to go wrong. And he got them back to the negotiating table, just by singular force of will, when everybody else on that campus had fled. And so this guy I'd met, briefly in Washington, all of a sudden, had something magical about him where he could operate and do things and had sort of a charisma and a bravery and a talent for this that I just wanted to get to know him better. Chris started following Johnson around Mondrovia, the capital. So, Mondrovia is a city built in a mix of jungle and swamp. It's like being in Florida at the height of summer.
我们在红灯市场闲逛，试图找到所有生活在边缘、从事这些非法活动并试图了解这一切如何运作的年轻人。它被称为红灯区，因为它是利比里亚第一个红灯信号灯所在地，而不是我们拥有红灯区的通常原因，但它也是那种红灯区。它应有尽有。街道两旁林立着出售燃料、旧衣服、美容产品、廉价电子产品的摊贩。零星地，男人们四处闲逛。约翰逊带着克里斯走进简陋的小屋、毒窟，在那里他们遇到了从事非法活动的前战斗人员。我们就坐在那里，和这些家伙聊天，谈论生意。
And we're wandering the red light market to try to find all of these young men living on the fringes doing these illegal activities, trying to understand how all that works. It's called the red light district because it was the site of Liberia's first traffic light, not for the normal reason that we have red light districts, but it was also that kind of red light district. It was everything. The streets were lined with vendor selling fuel, use clothes, beauty products, cheap electronics. Here and there, men loitered around. Johnson took Chris into small shacks, drug dens, where they met former combatants engaged in illegal activity. And we'd sit there and we'd just chat with these guys and we'd talk business.
你如何赚钱？你有多少客户？你是怎么落得这个地步的？下一步是什么？我确实记得从其中一个较大的毒窟走出来，
How do you make money? How many customers do you get? How do you end up doing this? What's next? I do remember coming out of this one of these bigger drug dens and You're kind of blinking in the sunlight and as we're coming out this this guy comes to us from across the street And he was shining shoes and he gives Johnson a big hug and they they're talking and catching up and I said Oh, how do you so how do you guys know one another?
你在阳光下眨着眼睛，当我们出来时，这个家伙从街对面朝我们走来。他是个擦鞋匠，给了约翰逊一个大大的拥抱，他们交谈并叙旧。我说：“哦，你们是怎么认识的？”
And he said well, I used to be like, and he points across the street to the drug then we just left. And then I went through Johnson's program. As the days went by, Chris met more and more men who approached Johnson to thank him for helping them turn their lives around. Chris got curious. What was going on? They sat down together at a cafe to talk.
他说：“嗯，我以前就像，”他指着街对面我们刚离开的毒窟。然后我经历了约翰逊的项目。随着日子一天天过去，克里斯遇到越来越多的人，他们走近约翰逊，感谢他帮助他们扭转了生活。克里斯好奇了。发生了什么事？他们坐在一起在咖啡馆交谈。
Johnson told Chris he was inviting groups of young people on the fringes of Mondrovia to attend a series of meetings. They won the first thing they would always do is they'd talk about how you present yourself. Because a lot of these guys are not showered, they don't keep pair of themselves, they're wearing cattered clothing, they don't look respectful, they look tough.
约翰逊告诉克里斯，他正在邀请蒙罗维亚边缘的一群年轻人参加一系列会议。他们第一件要做的事总是谈论你如何展现自己。因为这些家伙很多都没有洗澡，不修边幅，穿着破烂的衣服，看起来很不尊重人，看起来很强硬。
Johnson would introduce a special guest. And he said, if you want, we've got a guy here who can give you a haircut. And by that, I mean, he had a chair, a mirror, and a razor blade. And you'd shed your facial hair or the fuzz or whatever you have that signals that you're not a Part of normal society can go and you're not compelled to it's just an option and
约翰逊会介绍一位特别嘉宾。他说，如果你愿意，我们这里有个人可以帮你理发。我的意思是，他有一把椅子、一面镜子和一把剃须刀。你可以刮掉面部的毛发、绒毛，或者任何表明你不是正常社会成员的东西，你可以去，这不是强迫你的，只是一种选择，而且
That was their big event is maybe half the guys he said would would do that and The others would sort of sit back and say I'm not so so sure about this and So it was just about let's take that first baby step. And on day two, some of the guys who did get their haircut come back. And they've also gotten, you know, a polo shirt and maybe a pair of khaki pants, and they're wearing shoes instead of flip flops.
这就是他们的大事件，他说大概有一半的人会这么做，而其他人则会坐在一旁说，我对这个不太确定。所以这只是关于迈出第一步。到了第二天，有些理过发的人回来了。他们还穿上了Polo衫，也许还有一条卡其裤，他们穿的是鞋子而不是人字拖。
And the clothes aren't as dirty and they're not as patched. And they're certainly not sending that, that sort of badass signal. And they're invited to talk about what happened the last day or two, like, what was your experience? And most of them are like, it was amazing. Like, nobody recognized me.
而且衣服没那么脏了，也没有那么多补丁。他们当然也没有再发出那种不好惹的信号。他们被邀请谈谈过去一两天发生了什么，比如，你的体验是什么？他们大多数人的回答是，太神奇了。根本没人认出我。
And when they did, they were laughing. And I went into this store and nobody kicked me out. And most of them just talked about how amazing this was. Johnson told Chris that in subsequent meetings, he would talk to the young man about dealing with everyday violence. What to do when something bad happened around them? They were finding themselves in a brawl once or twice a week. Their disputes would turn into yelling matches. Someone might get stabbed once in a while. And just managing these like
而且当他们认出我时，他们都在笑。我走进这家店，没有人把我赶出去。他们大多数人都只是在谈论这有多神奇。约翰逊告诉克里斯，在随后的会议中，他会和这些年轻男子谈论如何处理日常暴力。当身边发生不好的事情时该怎么办。他们发现自己每周会陷入一两次斗殴。他们的争执会变成大喊大叫。偶尔还会有人被刺伤。要处理好这些像
everyday interactions without violence is just hard. And it kind of seems inescapable. We all have these relationships in our life. Maybe it's your son or your mom or something where you can just, you kind of lose your temper six seconds into the, the speed. You don't do that with everybody, right? You can be totally calm and cool headed with 49 other people that day. And then, and then just lose it like that. So we all have relationships like that. And the problem was that there's just didn't evolve into yelling or when they lost it, somebody could get hurt. Johnson would ask the man to think about how their emotions flared up in these moments.
日常交往中没有暴力的冲突是很难的。而且这似乎是不可避免的。我们生活中都有这种关系。也许是你的儿子、你的妈妈或者其他人，在交流仅仅六秒钟后，你就会大发雷霆。你不会对所有人都这样，对吧？那天你可以对其他49个人完全冷静、头脑清醒。然后，就在那样的情况下失控了。所以我们都有这样的关系。问题在于，这些关系往往会演变成大喊大叫，或者当他们失控时，可能会有人受伤。约翰逊会要求这些人思考他们的情绪在这些时刻是如何爆发的。
What did it feel like to get angry? And then people stand up and then they tell their story. Like here's this time when, you know, I exploded and we lost our tempers and somebody got stabbed and who else has a story like that. And then they'd also talk about, okay, what do you do in that circumstance? How do you actually avoid that? How do you manage these hostile social situations? How do you manage that one relationship that goes from 0 to 60 in an instant?
生气是什么感觉？然后人们站起来，讲述他们的故事。就像某个时刻，你知道的，我爆发了，我们失去了理智，有人被刺伤了，还有谁有这样的经历。然后他们也会讨论，好吧，在这种情况下你该怎么做？你到底该如何避免这种情况？你如何管理这些充满敌意的社交局势？你如何处理那种瞬间从0加速到60的关系？
So at some point, soon after this, you go back and have a conversation with your wife and you tell her a little bit about what Johnson is doing. She's of course a psychologist. Describe to me what you told her Johnson was doing and how that conversation unfolded Chris. I said, do you remember that guy Johnson bore? We just wrote down everything he did in his program. Take a look at this. What does this look like to you? And she paged through and she read it. And she said, huh, this looks like,
所以在不久之后的某个时刻，你回去和你的妻子交谈，把约翰逊在做的事情告诉了她。她当然是一位心理学家。克里斯，请描述一下你当时告诉她约翰逊在做什么，以及那次对话是如何展开的。我说，还记得那个叫约翰逊·鲍尔的人吗？我们把他在项目中做的所有事情都记下来了。看看这个。你觉得这像什么？她翻看着并读了读。然后她说，哼，这看起来像，
you know, this looks like cognitive behavioral therapy. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I am Shankar Vedantam. Several years ago, the economist Chris Blatman, now at the University of Chicago, met a charismatic librarian. Johnson Bor was running a shoestring program of his own invention in the poorest areas of Mondrovia.
你知道的，这看起来像是认知行为疗法。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几年前，现任职于芝加哥大学的经济学家克里斯·布拉特曼遇到了一位有个人魅力的图书管理员。约翰逊·鲍尔在蒙罗维亚最贫困的地区经营着一个靠微薄资金维持的、自创的项目。
He was trying to divert troubled young men and women from a life of crime. Johnson didn't have a name for his program, but it was a form of cognitive behavioral therapy. Developed in the 1960s, CBT, as it's known, suggests that by paying attention to how we act and what we do, we can subtly change how we think and what we feel. At the core of the program is the idea of practice. If you practice behaving differently,
他试图让陷入困境的年轻男女远离犯罪生活。约翰逊并没有给他的项目起名字，但它是一种认知行为疗法。认知行为疗法（CBT）于20世纪60年代开发，它表明，通过关注我们的行为和所做的事情，我们可以微妙地改变我们的思维方式和感受。该项目的核心是实践的概念。如果你练习以不同的方式行事，
your outlook, thoughts and emotions will follow. As an economist, Chris wanted to know if Johnson's brief eight-week program had any effects. He launched an experiment tracking about a thousand young men in Liberia who were at high risk for crime and violence. Half was selected at random to go through Johnson's program. Chris remembers the setting of the first session. It was held in one of those buildings he'd seen coming in from the airport when he arrived in the country.
你的视野、思想和情感就会随之改变。作为一名经济学家，克里斯想知道约翰逊这个短暂的为期八周的项目是否有任何效果。他在利比里亚发起了一项实验，追踪大约一千名处于犯罪和暴力高风险中的年轻男子。其中一半人被随机挑选参加约翰逊的项目。克里斯还记得第一次会议的地点。它是在他刚抵达该国、从机场进城时看到的那些建筑中的一栋。
It was a six-story skyscraper that was half built when the war broke out, and at that point was just a concrete shell. So concrete floors, stairwell, and then open to the air a concrete shell. So concrete floors stairwell and then opened the air. And we were on the third floor and we had sort of 20 scarred and half broken plastic chairs in a circle. And Johnson and his assistants would stand in the middle and try to lead these guys in discussion.
这是一座六层高的摩天大楼，战争爆发时只建了一半，当时只剩下一个混凝土外壳。所以有混凝土楼层、楼梯间，然后完全敞开露天。这是一个混凝土外壳。所以有混凝土楼层、楼梯间，然后完全敞开露天。我们在三楼，围成一个圈放着大约20把破损了一半的塑料椅子。约翰逊和他的助手站在中间，试图引导这些人进行讨论。
Chris could tell that many of the young men at the meeting were there because of Johnson, but that didn't mean they were converts. About half of them are slouched in their chair, their arms are crushed, they're looking very skeptically. They're also cautious because they're surrounded by a bunch of guys like themselves, which is almost never a good situation. So it's a circumstance where they also have to be cautious. Maybe they'd been in a fight with that guy the previous week. One guy was a real holdout. Very hostile and tough in his demeanor,
克里斯看得出，会议上的许多年轻人在那里是因为约翰逊，但这并不意味着他们已经被感化了。大约有一半人瘫坐椅子上，双臂交叉，神情非常怀疑。他们也很谨慎，因为他们被一群和自己相似的人包围着，这几乎从来都不是什么好情况。所以这也是一个他们必须保持谨慎的环境。也许他们前一周还和那个人打过架。其中一个人是个真正的顽固分子。他的举止非常敌对和强硬，
like just don't mess with me. Slouched, arms crossed, frowning. Still there, though. Still coming for the first day, still coming for the next few days after that. Not engaging, not when people are given an opportunity to stand up and testify or tell some story or relate, was not engaged, but was just checking it out, sitting at the back of the room, and then one day he came back,
就像是“别惹我”。身体瘫坐，双臂交叉，眉头紧锁。不过他还是留下来了。第一天来，接下来的几天也继续来。不参与，当人们有机会站起来作证、讲述某个故事或建立联系时，他不参与，只是在一旁观察，坐在房间后面，然后有一天他回来了，
but of his own volition, he had gotten this haircut and trimmed his beard and was dressed nicely. And the only reason I knew it was him was because he sat down in the same chair that he was always in. And he was brought into the circle and he was engaged, but nobody made a big deal out of it. As if they knew that that wasn't the right thing to do. So it was really remarkable to see that change day by day of just and how they tried to present wasn't the right thing to do. So it was really remarkable to see that change day by day of just how they tried to present themselves to the world and how that could change their own behavior.
但完全是出于他自己的意愿，他理了发，修剪了胡须，穿着整齐。我认出他的唯一原因是他坐在他一直坐的那把椅子上。他被纳入了圆圈并且参与进去了，但没有人小题大做。就好像他们知道那样做是不对的。所以看到这种日复一日的变化真的很了不起，以及他们试图展现——那样做是不对的。所以看到这种日复一日的变化真的很了不起，以及他们试图向世界展现自己的方式，以及这如何改变他们自己的行为。
The experiment divided the thousand young men into two groups. After half received Johnson's program for eight weeks, the larger group was divided at random into two new groups. The first received a cash gift of $200. The other did not. Effectively, the experiment created four groups, men who received cash and therapy, men who received cash alone, men who received therapy alone, and men who received neither. The initial
该实验将一千名年轻男子分为两组。在其中一半人接受了为期八周的约翰逊项目后，较大的一组被随机分为两个新组。第一组获得了200美元的现金礼金。另一组则没有。实际上，该实验创造了四组人：接受现金和治疗的人、仅接受现金的人、仅接受治疗的人，以及两者都没接受的人。最初的
results were promising. Chris decided to test something much more ambitious. Would there be any benefits after 10 years? He asked a large group of experts what to expect. Most people thought that therapy alone would have no lasting effects whatsoever. And cash and therapy, the vast majority thought that the effects might be zero, or at least steeply dissipate. Almost no one predicted that they'd persist in any kind of strength. Chris recently finished tracking the men over 10 years. There were modest, long-term benefits for the men who received therapy alone. For the men who received cash only, it was a whole different story. For the men who received cash only, it was a whole different
结果很有希望。克里斯决定测试更具雄心的东西。10年后还会有什么益处吗？他询问了一大群专家会有什么预期。大多数人认为，单纯的治疗不会产生任何持久的效果。而对于现金加治疗，绝大多数人认为效果可能是零，或者至少会急剧消散。几乎没有人预测它们会以任何强度持续下去。克里斯最近完成了对这些人10年来的追踪。对于仅接受治疗的男性，有一些微弱的长期益处。而对于仅接受现金的男性，情况则完全不同。对于仅接受现金的男性，情况则完全不同
story. For the men who received cash only, they changed their life in the short run, but the business that they started failed. Maybe they got rained out and damaged goods or the police seized their wares or they were robbed. And so within a year, they were no different than people who had received neither program. And 10 years later, they were no different. But the men who received the therapy and the cash gift? Persistently through the life of the project, after one month, after one year, after 10 years, the man had received the therapy followed by the cash.
故事。对于仅接受现金的男性来说，他们在短期内改变了生活，但他们创办的企业失败了。也许他们遭遇了雨淋导致货物受损，或者警察没收了他们的商品，或者他们被抢劫了。因此，在一年之内，他们与那些既没有接受这个也没有接受那个项目的人没有任何区别。10年后，他们也没有任何区别。但是接受了治疗和现金礼金的男性呢？在项目的整个生命周期中持续如此，一个月后、一年后、10年后，接受了治疗紧接着获得现金的男性。
Their behavior was totally transformed. And so they were half as likely to be selling drugs if the control group. They were half as likely to be engaged in thefts and muggings. To the point we're at added up to an average of 26 fewer crimes per year per person that got both cash and therapy. I mean, that's an astonishing finding, Chris. Ten years after an eight-week intervention and $200, you know, so the net total cost of
他们的行为发生了彻底的转变。与对照组相比，他们贩毒的可能性降低了一半。他们参与盗窃和抢劫的可能性降低了一半。这甚至让那些同时获得现金和治疗的人平均每人每年减少了26起犯罪。我的天，这是一个惊人的发现，克里斯。在经历了为期八周的干预和200美元援助十年后，你知道的，所以干预的净总成本
the intervention is probably $500 per person. Ten years later, you're seeing a 50% reduction in robberies. I mean, that is astonishing. So it seems to come from the men who were the most far gone is where most of the crime and violence happens. And amongst those most far gone guys, this intervention in the first month helped them climb out of that hole. And the amazing thing is that once they climbed out of that hole, and even after, you know, a month after the
每人大概是500美元。十年后，你看到抢劫案减少了50%。我的意思是，这太惊人了。所以这似乎主要来自于那些情况最糟糕的人，绝大部分犯罪和暴力都发生在他们身上。在那些情况最糟糕的人当中，这种干预在第一个月帮助他们爬出了那个深坑。神奇的是，一旦他们爬出了那个深坑，甚至在干预一个月后，他们参与犯罪的可能性也变小了，他们没有再走回头路。你认为是什么解释了这样一个事实：现金转移似乎帮助认知行为疗法在效果上得以持久，尤其是当现金转移本身似乎没有发挥任何作用时？所以我想说，你知道，有证据表明，单纯的治疗在10年后依然具有冲击力。我们认为，现金的作用在于，你在第八周结束了治疗，然后你第二天还得吃饭，或者你还得找个地方睡觉。许多人不得不重新去抢劫、犯罪或贩毒来维持生计，或者至少那是他们最好的选择。
intervention, they were less likely to be engaged in crime, they stayed out. What do you think explains the fact that the cash transfer seems to have helped the cognitive behavioral therapy persist in terms of its effects, especially when the cash transfers don't seem to have done anything on their own? So I would say, you know, there is evidence that the therapy alone was impactful after 10 years. What the cash did, we think, is you finished therapy on week 8, and then you had to go and eat the next day, or you still had to find a place to sleep. And many men had to turn back to mugging or crime or drug dealing just to make ends meet, or at least that was their best option.
但如果我们给你200美元，首先是你的口袋里有了一点额外的钱，可以在糟糕的一周里生存下来，而不必诉诸犯罪。你可以找到住所，你可以买到食物，你可以买到更好的衣服。在那之后，你可能还能存下足够的钱来开个修鞋摊或做点小买卖。这给了你练习技能的机会。因此，如果CBT关乎实践，如果行为塑造思维，那么正是这种正向强化
But if we gave you $200, one is you had a little bit of extra money in your pocket to survive a bad week without turning to crime. You could get some shelter, you could get some food, you could get some better clothing. And you could also add enough money after that to maybe start a shoe science stand or a little petty business. And that gave you a chance to practice your skills. So if CBT is about practice and if behavior shapes thinking, then it was this positive reinforcement
以及继续练习良好行为的能力、全新的你以及你所穿戴上的这种新形象和新身份。它真正将其巩固下来，以至于几个月后，当钱花光时，你已经有了额外的两、四、六、八个月的练习时间。因此，美国也有许多项目在询问，我们能否应用治疗性干预来根本解决犯罪挑战？有人可能会看你在利比里亚的结果并说，太好了，克里斯·布拉特曼找到了
and an ability to keep practicing the good behaviors and the new you and this new image and identity you had put on for size. And it really entrenched it such that that some months later, when the money was gone, you had an extra two, four, six, eight months of practice. So there have been a number of programs in the United States as well that have asked, can we apply therapeutic interventions to basically address challenges of crime? And someone could look at your results in Liberia and say, great, Chris Blatman has found
灵丹妙药。我们所需要做的就是给人提供CBT和一些钱，我们就解决了很多城市的犯罪问题。这种想法有什么问题呢，克里斯？是的，我的意思是，想象一下，你去看医生，病情才诉说了一半。她就说，停在那儿。泰诺加放疗。我们要面面俱到。
the magic pill. All we need to do is give people CBT and some money, and we've solved the crime problem in many cities. What's the problem with that kind of thinking, Chris? Yeah, I mean, imagine you went to your doctor and you were halfway through describing what was wrong with you. And she said, stop right there. Thailand on radiation. We're going to cover all the bases.
这对上一个人管用，对你也管用。你本能地知道你需要换个医生了。然而，我们选出了芝加哥或纽约的市长。我们希望他们告诉我们秘诀就是泰诺加放疗。我们希望他们说，哦，纽约实施了截查搜身，或者纽约实施了热点警务，或者纽约实施了CBT什么的，然后让我们把这个现成的解决方案拿来
That work for the last guy, it'll work for you. You would instinctively know that you need to get a new doctor. And yet we elect a mayor in Chicago or New York. And we want them to tell us the secret is Tylenol radiation. We want them to say, oh, New York did stop-infrisk, or New York did hot spots policing, or New York did CBT or something, and just let's take this off the shelf solution
一定对我们管用。而我们却跳过了诊断这一重要步骤。所以等一下，我们的暴力类型和那个地方一样吗？我们真的了解吗，因为暴力的根源不同，治疗必须符合诊断？克里斯和萨拉·海勒（我们在这个节目的早些时候听到过她的声音）正在芝加哥开展一项顺应利比里亚研究思路的干预措施。
must work for us. And we skip over that important step of diagnosis. And so wait a second, do we have the same kind of violence as that place? Do we really understand because there are some different roots of violence and the treatment has to fit the diagnosis? Chris and Sarah Heller, whom we heard from earlier in this program, are running an intervention along the lines of the Liberian study in Chicago.
它部分基于约翰逊·鲍尔的洞察，即你可以通过治疗性干预改变人们的生活轨迹。它也基于萨拉的洞察，即把人们视为潜在受害者，而不是潜在肇事者，既能降低他们成为受害者的风险，又能降低他们犯罪的倾向。芝加哥干预的数据仍属初步。这是一个令人难以置信的有希望的结果，因枪击和凶杀而导致的逮捕数量大幅减少，改善幅度超过了50%。
It's based partly on Johnson Boors' insight that you can change the course of people's lives with therapeutic interventions. And it's based on Sarah's insight that thinking about people as potential victims, rather than as would-be perpetrators, has the capacity to both reduce their risk of becoming victims and their propensity to commit crime. The data out of the Chicago intervention is still preliminary. There's an incredibly promising result, a huge reduction in arrests for shooting in homicides, more than a 50% improvement.
另一方面，他们因其他类型的暴力犯罪而被捕的可能性略有增加，虽然没有那么严重，但并没有像我们预期的那样朝着同一个方向发展。而在中间地带，他们自己被枪击的可能性实际上更低，但这种下降幅度并没有那么大，也不是我们所说的统计学意义上的显著。所以平均来看，这有点模棱两可。另一方面，如果你根据对社会的成本和对这些年轻人的成本来权衡这些事情，毫无疑问，这是一个巨大的改善。在蒙罗维亚起作用的方法在芝加哥可能不会完全以同样的方式起作用。弄清楚在特定地区什么方法管用的唯一方法，就是花时间诊断问题并对不同的干预措施进行仔细评估。但克里斯、萨拉和许多其他研究人员正在探索的工作中蕴含着广泛的洞察。其中最重要的一点是，犯罪警匪剧的旧模式——
On the other hand, they're slightly more likely to be arrested for other types of violent offenses, not nearly as serious, but not running in the same direction like we expected. And then in the middle, they're actually less likely to get shot themselves, but that decrease is not so large, nor is it what we'd say is statistically significant. And so on average, it's kind of ambiguous. On the other hand, if you weight these things by the cost of society and the cost of the young men, it's unambiguous that this is just a huge improvement. What works in Mondrovia might not work exactly the same way in Chicago. The only way to figure out what works in a given area is to spend time diagnosing the problem and conducting careful evaluations of different interventions. But there are broad insights from the work that Chris and Sarah and many other researchers are exploring. One of the most important is that the old model of crime show dramas
好人追捕坏人，而坏人从不改过自新——那个模式是错误的。我们有点认为这些人天生如此而且无可救药，什么都不会改变。他们是死硬的罪犯或死硬的杀手。而且，我认为我们所看到的是，这根本不是真的。这些年轻人大多数都想摆脱这种生活。如果你给他们机会，他们会接受。而且，如果你们提供的任何东西奏效，他们很有可能会摆脱这种生活，或者至少暴力程度会大大降低。克里斯·布拉特曼是芝加哥大学的经济学家和政治学家。
with good guys chasing bad guys and bad guys never changing their ways, that model is wrong. We kind of assume these people are born into this and stuck and nothing will change. That they're hardened criminals or hardened killers. And, and I think what we see is that's just not true. That most of these young men want a way out of this life. They will take it if you give it to them. And then if whatever you're offering them works, there's a good chance they'll get out of that life for at least a lot less violent. Chris Blackman is an economist and political scientist at the University of Chicago.
他是《我们为何而战：战争的根源与和平之路》一书的作者。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德维克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是嘉莉·霍夫曼。嘉莉领导公共广播交换所，即PRX。她是整个公共广播领域的主要战略家之一，在过去几年里，她一直是《隐藏的大脑》的挚友。
He is the author of Why We Fight, the Roots of War and the Paths to peace. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Carrie Hoffman. Carrie heads up the public radio exchange or PRX. She is one of the leading strategists across all of public radio and over the last few years she has been a great friend to Hidden Brain.
当我创立Hidden Brain Media时，我和嘉莉就播客、广播节目以及构建稳定、自我维持、高质量新闻的更广阔艺术进行了多次对话。她总是体贴入微、慷慨大方，而且聪明绝顶。谢谢你，嘉莉。我真的很感激。
As I launched Hidden Brain Media, I've had many conversations with Kerry about podcasts and radio shows, and the larger art of building stable, self-sustaining, high quality journalism. She's always thoughtful, always generous, and wicked smart. Thank you, Kerry. I'm really grateful.
如果你是《隐藏的大脑》的支持者，谢谢你。如果你不是，请帮助我们制作更多这样的节目。当你支持我们时，你是在告诉我们你支持我们。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，如果你想帮助我们继续打造你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 并进行赞助。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，回头见。你本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文中的任意句子即可发表评论。
If you're a supporter of Hidden Brain, thank you. If you're not, please help us to produce more shows like this. When you support us, you're telling us you have our back. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help us keep building the show you love go to support.hiddenbrain.org and pitching. I'm Shankar Vedantam see you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你是Hidden Brain的支持者，谢谢你。如果你还不是，请帮助我们制作更多这样的节目。当你支持我们时，你是在告诉我们你支持我们。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一次，如果你想帮助我们继续制作你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 并进行赞助。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，我们很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。